[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe auf kinder ist einen food trend
entdeckt und zwar nennt das ich vor
caccia garten vor katja das ist ja ein
wirklich super luftiges flüssiges brot
ich sag dieses wort in letzter zeit zu
oft fluffig egal aber es gibt einfach
keine andere beschreibung dafür und für
katja garden bedeutet dass dieses brot
wie so eine blumenwiese wird wie
sonnenblumen landschaft und das machen
wir heute also das brot an sich ist
super lecker aber wenn es dann noch so
wunderschön aussieht perfekt oder also
machen wir dies zuerst einmal mache ich
jetzt den vor katja teig das ist ein
ganz normaler hefeteig und besteht aus
nur wenigen zutaten die ich persönlich
immer zu hause haben dafür nehme ich
einen würfel hefe 550 gramm warmes
wasser einen esslöffel zucker 900 gramm
mehl ich habe jetzt hier ein dinkelmehl
630 drei teelöffel salz und 100 gramm
olivenöl
das ganze geht auch recht schnell in dem
jetzt einfach die hefe die kommt hier in
die küchenmaschine ihr könnt den teig
aber auch ganz gut mit der hand
verkneten
dann kommt das wasser dazu mit dem
zucker verrühren alles auch noch ein
bisschen bis man nämlich gefrorene hefe
ich habe mich immer hefe auf vorrat im
gefrierschrank und dann nehme ich sie
einfach raus und löste in den warmen
wasser auch funktioniert super jetzt
einfach noch die restlichen zutaten
dazugeben
wie gesagt habe ich jetzt hier ein
dinkelmehl das 630 er könnte aber auch
einen weizenmehl nehmen oder sogar
weizenmehl und vollkommen halb halb
mission salz und öl immer zum schluss
dazu und dann ist einfach nur ganz
wichtig dass der teig wirklich wie etwa
zehn minuten geschmeidig geknetet wird
denn dadurch wird da immer besser also
entweder gibt es dann halt
muskeltraining für eure arme oder eben
für die küchenmaschine
es gibt hier sogar noch direkt wissen
hitze drauf dann geht er gleich noch
schneller auf
der teig ist jetzt perfekt ihr seht
schon ich habe die zwischenzeit genutzt
und habe schon mal mein gemüse
vorbereitet deswegen liebe ich es
einfach die maschine arbeitet und die
sally auch das schiff also das ist so
ein bisschen weiterer hefeteig wie man
sehen kann und das ist auch gut so damit
das brot später schön luftig wird und
ich habe jetzt den tiger mit hitze
verknetet der so richtig schön warm da
geht auch schnell auf und jetzt gebe ich
den tag an hat damit noch schneller geht
ganz kurz in den backofen bei der stufe
34 grad mit bisschen dampf stoß so
trocknet der teig nicht aus ihr könnt
ihn aber auch ganz einfach abdecken mit
einem geschirrtuch bisschen mit öl
einstreichen und lasst den ganzen eine
stunde aufgehen ich werde in der
zwischenzeit schon mal das gemüse
vorbereiten und schaue noch mal kurz im
garten was wir noch so haben was mit auf
die focaccia pracht
[Musik]
hallo danke schön mein reden ist
bisschen gewachsen
noch ein bisschen thymian das vom
bodendecker thymian das heißt der
bedeckt hielt den ganzen boden
das finde ich echt richtig schön mit
lauch ist auch immer gut
und dann gucken wir mal vorne noch eben
gemüse hochbett es gibt ja auch erst mal
blumen wie lavendel zum beispiel oder
allgemein alle blumen die ich hier vorne
habe diese messbar
ich glaube da nämlich auch einfach
bislang angenommen ein hirsch mccurry
kraut das ist auch es war ja da haben
wir doch schon blumen mein gott
kari kraut riecht auch echt extrem gut
ich glaube ich nehme noch so ein
bisschen was mit deko und geschmack
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in meinem job ich
bin jane und flieg hier gleich mit
liliana durchschnitt es ist halt echt
okay ist es wieder passiert unser garten
da explodiert hier die zitronenverbene
ich musste hier raus setzen dass ich ja
einen riesenbaum geworden und hier kraut
der unsterblichkeit also wenn wir das
alles essen ich fühle mich unsterblich
wow und hier mein papa hat es wieder
getan er hat wieder zucchini ins
hochbeet gesetzt und ich habe gesagt
papa mach schnaps macht man hier die
tomaten oh mein gott es ist alles etwas
zu viel aber auberginen habe ich schon
geerntet
guck mal ich bin auberginen pflanzen so
schön
heute habe ich vorhin schon abgeerntet
und die militärs als ich würde mal
behaupten wenn man den knoblauch essen
kann kann man auch seine blume essen
für salat gurke
ich glaube der papa hat schon alle
tomaten geerntet
eine habe ich noch
kaum was soll der geiz die nehmen wir
jetzt auch noch mit
[Musik]
die auf g zeit des tages muss ich jetzt
noch ein bisschen um welches gemüse
vorbereiten
also ich habe hier einfach eine bunte
mischung ihr könnt nehmen was euch
schmeckt was euch gut gefällt ich habe
ich tomaten aus dem garten rote und
gelbe dann hier noch ein paar szenen aus
dem garten etwas sesam oliven
schwarzkümmel dann habe ich ja noch
radieschen und rote zwiebeln
vielleicht nehme ich noch die rote beete
dann frühlingszwiebeln wirklich super da
ich diese ganz toll als blumstengel
benutzen kann da noch bisschen was
orangen des gelbes und rotes und alles
was ich eben so aus dem garten noch
mitgenommen habe weil er gelbe paprika
oder allgemein bei paprika ist es so am
besten drückt ihr diesen stengel hier
rein
denn man möchte so wenig verlust wie
möglich dann den deckel wegschneiden
boden wegschneiden und dann einfach hier
alle vier seiten und was dann übrig
bleibt ist nur noch das innere und ihr
habt wirklich null verlust
hier mache ich jetzt gleich eine
sonnenblume draus machen möchte
schneidet in streifen ja dann nämlich
die einzelnen blüten
[Musik]
die tomaten die halbe ich jetzt einfach
die maschine muss ich schon mal
verarbeiten
sie muss noch ein bisschen entwässert
werden
wie schneidet die daraus könnte ich
wollte die fernseh blumen machen
ich glaube ich schneide dir einfach oder
vielleicht kann man so was hinter was
jetzt bei der aubergine ganz wichtig ist
damit die einfach auch ihre bitterstoffe
verliert mit bisschen salz vermischen
das wird auch später wieder ausgewaschen
und ich versuche jetzt mal einzufärben
mit roter beete vielleicht klappt's
probieren wir bei roter beete immer
handschuhe anziehen
außer ihr wollt mit pinkfarbenen händen
rumlaufen
meine hände sind doch sowieso nichts
machen es vor
das habe ich nicht einfach die hände
abgedrückt hat
[Musik]
sie schneidet es noch ein paar scheiben
runter eine scheibe lege ich dazu geht
noch wasser drauf und lass einfach die
aubergine ein bisschen ziehen so was
aber noch zwiebel auf jeden fall ins
zwiebelringe karotten die würde ich auch
in ringe sind zu schreiben kann man
schöne blüten legen und wenn ihr das so
aus der hand nicht gut schneiden können
mit dem messer nicht gleichmäßig können
da eine hohe benutzen und dann habt ihr
auch einfach schöne feine karotten
scheibe bei den zwiebeln einfach hier
vorne noch die wurzel wegnehmen und dann
würde ich sagen wo ich den teig denn der
ist schon seit und das problem ist
einfach und gucken wie es aussieht
abgänger paradies ziehen und dann gucken
wir das aussieht
[Musik]
die aubergine die geste ich jetzt
einfach kurz ab die schale weg die hatte
ich kurz erwärmt damit ist die farbe
besser nimmt nämlich ein bisschen
olivenöl
ich habe den teig gerade noch kurz
abgedeckt weiler etwas hoch gegangen ist
und jetzt könnt ihr euer brot entweder
eckig oder rund machen
ich probiere mal beide ist weil ich noch
nicht so ganz weiß was mir besser
gefällt ich nehme hier einmal die dauer
back folie für das eckige brot und im
prinzip kommt jetzt einfach drauf an wie
groß ist machen wollt also aus dieser
teig menge schaffe ich bestimmt drei bis
vier brote heck ich brauche ich ein
bisschen mehr teig wird sie einfach mit
der hand so ein bisschen öffnen
also erzählt man braucht man auch nicht
wirklich werkzeug dafür das gebe ich
kurz zur seite
da kann es nämlich nur bisserl
entspannen und fürs runde nämlich
einfach ein ermittler
auch ein bisschen fett
[Musik]
okay ich hab jetzt doch nur ein rechteck
und einen kreis draus gemacht denn ich
will ja auch steve o katja die soll ja
auch schön luftig werden also und dann
geht es los dann könnt ihr eure
blumenwiese gestalten also ich glaube
als basis nämlich auf jeden fall
zwiebeln die blumen stengel sozusagen
ihr könnt ihr auch einfach kürzen so ein
bisschen rein drücken
alles was ich heute nicht brauch wird
später um salat und ich starte mit
meiner sonnenblume
wie kommt hier rein
da gebe ich jetzt in die mitte etwas
schwarz kümmern
[Musik]
ich war einfach so einem halben urwald
geerntet ihr müsst ja nicht so voll
packen aber ich muss schön was meint ihr
okay ripplinger findet kitschig ich
finde so das ok oder vielleicht noch ein
bisschen sesam
das stellt die pollen fliegen umher
jetzt bestreite ich hier den teig noch
ein bisschen mit öl und dann kommt die
focaccia in den kalten backofen
und dann schalte ich den backofen an und
maxi und dann gucken wir mal wie es am
ende aussieht aber ich finde es schon
machen wir noch die runde
[Musik]
und jetzt alle zusammen in sola
kochsendung so was bei ihr so war es bei
topfgeldjäger dann war immer ein
publikum selten und dann haben die immer
angestimmt und herren sowie der anklage
oder der anlasser haha und dann lachen
alle
ja kann man wieder alle kurz lachen wir
sind hier vor das studio nein also hier
[Musik]
ich wollte auch schon mal an klatscher
seien eher auch okay also hier ist meine
version der frau katja garten und ich
find sie wirklich wunderschön ich habe
nochmal die gleiche menge teig gemacht
um sozusagen noch zwei weitere zu machen
also aus einer menge habe ich wie gesagt
zwei stück hinbekommen
ein rundes und ein eckiges und ihr könnt
ja so groß oder klein machen wie ihr
möchtet was auch schön ist denn so mini
focaccia garten wird dann jeder einfach
so ein eigenes brot hat man kann ja auch
was zum kindergeburtstag machen und die
kinder können selber ihre blumen drauf
legen also ich glaube da gibt es
wirklich genug anlässe und ich glaube
auch zum muttertag zum vatertag oder
geburtstag freut man sich über so ein
selbstgebackenes brot zwar ins
anschneiden
ich finde es schon irgendwie bisschen
schade aber der schmerz
als auf der back folie bitte nicht
schneiden auf einem blech jetzt ganz gut
so mit blume sonne
ich wollte freuen doch sagen auch mir
fehlt so ein bisschen der knoblauch
geschmack weil vorkasse ist für mich
immer einfach kollegen etwas knoblauch
aber ich habe ja noch knoblauch mit drin
also dieses knoblauch lauch und guckte
mal wie schön war ich mega das lassen
wir uns jetzt gleich hier schmecken
ich habe übrigens aus den resten einfach
noch tipps gemacht hier einmal paprika
dip mit joghurt hier einmal schnittlauch
mit joghurt und alle tomaten reste
zwiebeln usw
einfach eingekocht als tomatensoße das
gibt es jetzt hier bei uns zum mittag
ich hoffe dass euch diese idee gefällt
teilt sie auch gerne und vor allem macht
die focaccia garten nach verlinkt mich
mit dem hashtag tenniswelt oder sallys
focaccia werden
und dann finde ich auch eure beiträge
und kannst du mir anschauen und ich bin
richtig gespannt darauf was für
kunstwerke ihr aus eurem brot zaubern
wertet und bis zum nächsten mal
ich werde noch eine süße variante davon
machen so mit aprikosen und kirschen ja
das machen wir auch also bis dann
[Musik]